I would walk into the Octagon overly
relaxed and do you think that that was
contributed to by your time and yes like
Lee korlinski when I was fighting for
the IFL I remember the first time that
he ever saw me fight he's like what is
wrong with you Leo it's fine bro just
like go sit down I'm gonna go fight in a
minute he's like you are gonna go fight
in a minute can you like recognize that
you're about to go fight yeah yeah go
out knock the guy out in the first round
so it took like 10 fights for Leo to
realize that like everything's even in
fighting the weight class is very
specific your opponent is picked so that
you guys have a competitive fight
because nobody wants to watch a prime
Mike Tyson fights a 43 year old fat
white dude that came off the couch like
that's not interesting they want to see
like two apex predator Peak athletes go
head to head you know Gorilla versus
Bear even the referee his purpose there
is to make sure that we not just are
safe but that we also fight under the
constrictions and the limitations that
are the rule set which makes it very
competitive